Hey,
what's going on is bill burr and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
April 15th,
2013.
How are you,
how are you doing this week?
Do you feel like this week is going to be a good one?
Um,
today's episode is brought to you by tig.
there,
yeah.
Sports Fan drum set,
that's the proper word.
Um,
seeing that dude Luke come off the bench and hit fucking,
uh,
three 43 pointers in a row and after three that alleyoop jam was the sickest
thing that dude spike whatever.
I'm not the biggest college hoop fair spike whatever fucking for Michigan.
Okay.
You know what law ahead was joking about?
I said in the,
he was joking like saying in the first half it was white dude's dominating the
game with outside shots.
Of course God knows wouldn't when our game has never been above the rim.
White dudes would dominating that game.
And then in the second half,
black dudes just took it over and Bly head was cracking us up saying basically
they were doing a reenactment of basketball history.
I liked the first sack half was like when fuck and a Bob Cousy,
you know,
back when you couldn't put your hand on the side of the ball,
you had to fucking look.
You had to have it right on top of the ball.
You have a watch that she had watched old basketball highlights and people
always go like,
oh my God,
these guys suck.
They didn't suck.
If you put,
if you put your hand on the side of the ball to go to this side,
that was considered a carry.
They've made all these fucking rules where a,
what did,
uh,
by the way have all been great rules,
you know,
to allow these athletes to reach the reach,
the pinnacle of their,
there's their,
uh,
their sports at history.
I almost didn't get that out.
Um,
okay.
But it was just,
it was an unbelievable game.
And there was this fucking Louisville fan sitting behind us and dude,
I got to tell you,
we were on the lower level and we still needed binoculars.
I'm not even gonna lie to you.
I mean,
it was like if we were at a,
if we were at like at an Atlanta Falcons game,
we would have been eighth row in the end zone.
All right.
Cause we literally could see the wall where they would actually have like the,
the post nine 11 people glaring at you with their yellow coats on,
you know,
uh,
but instead,
because it was basketball,
there was,
there was like a fenced area where you couldn't go past.
And then there was a whole nother section of about 20 rows of these padded
seats.
Right.
And then in front of that was a whole nother 20 section of just students.
And it was some Michigan kids who,
by the way,
Michigan used to be the blue and maize.
Now it's just the maze.
Um,
I got to tell you that some of these fucking uniforms and some of the shit just,
it's the loudest Shit I've seen since the 79 pirates.
And I considering that they're in the midst of making anchorman part too.
I think it's very,
I was actually thinking that,
you know,
how they make,
they,
they make fun of the clothes from back then in like the late seventies and
everything when they,
when they do the anchorman of this,
this time right now,
you know,
with sports and that type of thing.
If there's ever somebody as big as a genius has,
Will Ferrell and like 20 years is making fun of this era.
It's going to be shit like that.
Like those uniforms when Michigan played Syracuse,
I mean,
that was just fucking ridiculous.
Those yellow sneakers and the orange sneakers,
that's,
that's just something I would,
I'm going to say within maybe four years,
well,
actually probably four years,
it'll start to die off.
So I'll say within 10 years you're going to look back at those things.
It'd be like,
Jesus Christ the fuck were we thinking.
Um,
I saw a couple of Michigan fans with the old school,
like,
you know the blue where it says Michigan and yellow.
It's funny.
Tell it which it,
it looked like a fucking,
it look at HD mustard and they were all chanting go blue.
Like you guys don't have any fucking blue on anymore,
but I have to tell you we were,
so we was sitting on the Michigan side.
Okay.
And you know,
I flunked everything in fucking high school
and they used to sit there and try and scare the shit out of me.
You know,
going,
you need till years,
little language.
You got a big show,
your GPA is above a 3.6 you're not going to get it above a bunny sat there and
you sit in that fucking nod off just not giving a shit.
I've got to tell you,
I once did that fucking basketball game
and the entire student section turned around,
faced us and like almost just doing like this half Tomahawk Chop think they
will.
They went go and then everybody behind this when Blue Oh blue,
the whole fucking section going nuts.
Okay.
And I said the fucking version.
I said,
you know,
my freshman in high school year in high school,
instead of scaring the shit out of me academically,
they just showed,
it should have showed me a video of this going,
you know what?
If you actually study in high school,
you can participate in something like this,
and I would have been like,
well,
you know what?
I'm going to go home and hit the books.
I would have done that.
Instead of telling me all the academic shit that I need,
they should have showed me how fun college could have been if I actually studied
and went to a real fucking school.
No,
I didn't.
I completely,
I fucked up my freshman year of high school.
I went in there and I was thinking I was going to be old and I was going to go
to Notre Dame University.
Those were my goals.
By the time sophomore year came around,
I was looking at Wentworth college and I was considering getting into
construction.
Okay,
what a fucking idiot.
Now I go around all these big schools,
you know,
I fucking go to these games,
go like an Lsu game or a Georgia bulldog game.
Ohio state,
Michigan.
Just go to these fucking things and you just see these kids.
I hope the kids appreciate it.
Maybe that's what,
you know.
I think maybe you have to be like me to really fucking appreciate how awesome it
is to go to a school.
Okay.
That has such an insane fucking sports program.
You,
this is what I'm jealous about those colleges kids,
is that for the rest of their lives,
they can kind of stay connected to that college by following the teams.
And if they ever want to have like a mini reunion with the tailgate friends,
you just pick a game once a year when you go to what and have a great fucking
time,
you know?
Oh Jesus,
did I fuck up?
It's making me sad.
Um,
but you know what makes me happy?
Everybody never having to go to the post office again.
Huh?
Oh,
that was a nice segue.
stamps.com everybody you a postage meter companies used to have to have the
monopoly on printing postage.
They could charge you an arm and a leg to print postage from your own office,
but those days are over.
Now you can use stamps.com instead with stamps.com you can get all the benefits
of a postage meter,
but at the fraction of the cost,
all you need to do,
all you need is your computer printer and stamps.com to get official us postage
for any letter or any package,
any class of mail.
Plus you'll never have to set step foot in the post office again.
I'm everything you would need to do with the post office,
you could do right from your own desk.
It's so convenient.
I don't know why you wouldn't do it.
If somebody is dumb as me can use stamps.com you know,
to send out my DVDs to all my wonderful shows.
Um,
look,
if I can figure it out.
So can you,
so don't be intimidated.
Don't be an old fuddy duddy me,
like why?
I've always gone to the post office and I still want to go because it's
comfortable.
Step outside your comfort zone and improve your quality of life.
Right now.
Use My last name.
[inaudible] B U R for this special offer.
No risk trial plus $110 bonus offer includes a digital scale and a $55 free
postage.
Don't wait.
Go to stamps.com before you do anything else,
click on the microphone at the top of the homepage and type in burpee.
You are our that stamps.com enter burr.
All right,
back to the podcast.
Don't save.
There we go.
Well,
the hell am I?
All right.
Let's,
uh,
let's get to reading some of your questions for this week.
Um,
oh,
I didn't,
I never finish that story.
So we get done.
Um,
we,
we go,
we did Athens the first night
down.
Uh,
what does that,
it's northeast of Atlanta.
First day we went to the basketball game.
The next day,
the tour starts right now.
You have to go to work,
pay for all the fucking money.
We spent the night before.
I don't,
I don't think at the end of this,
I don't think I made any money,
but I had a great fucking time.
All right.
Um,
my quarterly taxes it dude,
this is going to be a rough one.
Somebody's going to be eating fruit loops.
Um,
so we do Athens,
Georgia first,
right?
And we're all fucking giddy.
Just freaking out.
We do the Gig.
Have a great time.
This beautiful theater.
I really don't have any funny fucking stories because everything just worked out
this week.
Um,
it was a Tuesday night.
The place was packed.
Um,
what happened on that show?
Nothing.
We just had a great time.
I did have to get into with one guy.
Okay.
One guy just kept screaming and yelling.
He was too excited.
So I went off on him and I ended it with,
I'm ashamed of you,
which is quite possibly one of the funnies things.
One grown man could say to another one.
I am ashamed of you.
Um,
then we got off.
We got on the bus because we were,
uh,
we were driving up to,
oh.
Did we stay on the bus at night?
No,
no,
no.
We drove up to Hoover,
Alabama.
Oh,
I know.
I can take you through the week.
So we go up to Hoover,
Alabama to play this.
The next night we go up there fucking Alabama,
by the way.
Absolutely beautiful fucking state.
I would retire.
I'm actually thinking about retiring there for the simple fact.
Nobody fucking retires there.
Even never heard that in your life.
People retire where they go out west.
Everybody goes to fucking Arizona,
right?
And out east.
Everybody goes to Florida.
The Midwest people,
they retire in the Carolinas.
All right?
Nobody fucking retires.
Nobody from outside of Alabama retires in Alabama hedge,
you can get like 90 acres for about $67.
Go out there.
Get me a spread.
Right?
I don't know.
I couldn't get a direct flight anywhere that would suck less.
I was going to Mississippi.
But who cares at that point?
I think that that's what you do is you fucking,
you go to a really expensive fucking places like New York,
La,
Chicago,
and you bust your fucking ass your whole fucking life.
You make a bunch of goddamn money.
And then in the end you retire to a beautiful state that nobody wants to go to
for some stupid fucking reason.
And then all the,
all the assets that you've accrued,
you sell those things and there were three times as much down and fucking
Alabama.
He just retire there.
Get yourself a giant fucking dish.
You get all the sports channels.
It's not,
they don't have food down there,
you know,
and then pick a school,
Alabama,
Auburn,
Crimson tide,
a war eagle,
and enjoy yourself.
Just a good old boy.
Right?
So then we did Hoover,
Alabama,
and this is the best part right after Hoover out Alabama.
We had to be in Columbia,
South Carolina the next night,
which I've never been to.
So it was one of those deals where as the second the show was over,
we got on the bus and we just started driving.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
we got a bottle,
a makers and we just started pouring drinks.
We popped in fucking anchorman.
Watch that,
laughed our asses off.
And uh,
I dunno,
we just polished off the bottle somewhere in about four or five hours into the
fucking trip,
by the way.
We're supposed to be sleeping.
Okay.
And the bus driver who slept during the day,
he's supposed to be up driving,
you know,
so we get about four hours into this eight hour trip and then we pull out,
the guy pulls over the bus and he goes,
look,
uh,
he's like,
we're going to get there too early,
you know,
for when we check in at the hotels,
so we just got to kind of chill here for a minute,
sleep on the bus and were like,
yeah,
cool.
No worries.
So he goes to,
he goes to bed,
I'm going to bed.
He goes to bed and we keep fucking drinking.
Somewhere in the middle of that,
yeah,
me and version,
you get into this giant fucking New York Boston argument
that I think went on for like 40 fucking minutes.
It was hilarious.
Absolutely hilarious.
And then got real for like three minutes and then got hilarious again.
I'm so fucking stupid people from those two cities.
We'll never get along.
And then finally,
I don't know what happened at like five in the morning.
I was just like,
guys,
I got to go to bed,
right.
Versie and fucking la.
Hell yeah,
no worries.
No worries.
Right.
So I fucking go back and in the back,
go to bed.
And uh,
evidently first he law had just kept going.
The bus driver wakes up at like eight 30 in the morning,
comes from the back,
walks up to the front of the bus,
opens the door.
Eddie sees fucking law ahead and versus still sitting there drinking.
And he goes,
man,
you gotta be fucking kidding me.
And uh,
I'm not gonna name names or anything like that,
but this bus driver has seen a lot of shit.
He's driven a lot of people.
So to get this guy to be like,
man,
you gotta be shitting me was,
was a major fucking accomplishment.
Uh,
I'll take you through the 12 real quick.
So then the next night we were a,
we drove into a,
okay,
Columbia,
South Carolina,
which is from what I hear,
just like Savannah,
Georgia,
except Nasser is the people there said.
And um,
I dunno,
I got up around like one o'clock,
two o'clock or some shit.
And I just walked two miles from where we parked the bus outside the hotel and
then went down to the whole old area of,
uh,
of South Carolina,
Columbia,
South Carolina.
It was fucking insane.
This is a place where like bankers retired after they steal money for 60 years,
they,
they'd fucking,
I was sitting there walking down the street and,
um,
there's some horse drawn carriage thing that people are like taking a,
a,
a tour of the area and all these old homes.
The lady has the,
uh,
the rebel confederate hat on minus the flag.
Right?
And she's like,
if y'all look over there,
that house for sale for $9 million,
this old ass fucking house.
And I'm looking at it like probably a hundred to 150 years older than my house.
This thing may be is from the early 18 hundreds.
Right?
And,
uh,
if not the 17 hundreds.
And I'm just thinking of all the bullshit that I've gone through with my house
that's 90 years old and that's all I saw.
I'm like,
you're going to pay fucking $9 million for that.
Really?
That's what you're gonna do.
And you're going to be out fucking,
you know,
at the movies and a pipe is going to burst and you gonna have to deal with that
bullet.
Go Fuck Yourself.
If you play $9 million for a house,
you're an asshole.
You're an asshole.
All right?
You're in banking.
That's what I would guess.
You either in banking or you worked for insurance companies and collected
premiums.
And then when people's fucking gallbladders bursted you didn't give him the
fucking money either did that or you invented the Flowbee.
Other than that,
I don't know how you either just straight up steal shit legally or you fucking,
uh,
you come up with just some dumb shit.
The Jack Chop,
right.
Some sort of thing to chop up lettuce,
you know,
I'll make fat people more comfortable.
That's another one.
Right.
All right,
here we go.
I'm in limbo.
Hey Bill.
I'm 22 years old from the suburbs,
lawn guy land,
the youngest of four and I guess you could say I'm the black sheep of the
family.
I didn't go to college after high school mainly because I had no clue what I
wanted to do and I didn't see how spending three grand at a shitty community
college would help me figure that out.
Three grand.
Okay
Dude.
See now that's what you want to go to college.
We're just three grant.
You come out of the day,
you're not swimming in debt,
but you have no team to follow.
Um,
anyways,
however,
I'm a decent musician and have acted in a French student films and people told
me I'm somewhat talented in that area.
For the past year or so,
I become clinically depressed.
I feel that there isn't much left for me here and I'm sick of my friends.
I was thinking about moving to la with a friend and his brother.
I'm hoping I can find some things out there and just mainly to get away from the
life I have now.
Also looking forward to all the low self struggling actress ass.
I've heard so much about.
Um,
however,
over the last year or so,
my relationship with my family has met,
not been going so well.
Should I stick around and work on my life here and put the pieces back together
or go out there and meet some new people and have some new experiences?
Yeah.
Fucking come out to la or wherever the hell you want to go.
I think you're depressed because you're in a circle of people that are all
following the same fucking lead buffalo over,
over that cliff.
All right.
You're still going to go over a cliff as we all do,
but you want to be following a buffalo.
Let's go in the fucking direction you want to go to.
Oh my God.
He's using animals as a metaphor.
Um,
sir,
I would say,
I mean,
if you're clinically depressed,
I don't know if you have something fucking like,
uh,
like,
you know,
chemically going on,
I can't help you with that.
But if he just fucking depressed because you know,
doing what all your friends and family is doing and it's just soul sucking every
God damn day,
I can help you with that.
All right?
If you're clinically fucking depressed,
I mean you need to see a doctor or some shit,
you know,
I dunno.
See what sort of witchcraft he can offer you.
But if you just fucking depressed,
I mean,
I would definitely a go for a change of scenery.
Um,
but I would also say if you're stepping into the,
to a life of the arts,
like you,
you really,
you have to have a game plan the same way somebody who's going to become a
banker does.
Mike,
a banker goes,
okay,
um,
I'm going to join this evil business and I'm going to make as much fucking money
as I possibly can.
And if I have to make old people who actually fought for this country,
have to eat alto for the rest of their fucking lives because we're going to rape
and pillage their 401k's.
Um,
this is,
these are the steps I need to do.
One,
shut off all feelings for other human beings.
You know,
they,
they make a list,
justify my evil by saying I'm a small part of the bigger evil,
but my evil is actually a very low level of evil amongst the ridiculous level of
evil.
Um,
no,
like as far as
what I did,
um,
when I became a comedian was I just,
okay.
They were just very small steps.
One,
sit down and write jokes to sign up for open mic.
Three have the balls to go up there when they call your name for no matter how
bad or good it goes,
sign up for another open mic.
Yeah.
And just,
I just kept,
I just kept going to you kind of,
if you look too far down the fucking road,
it's going to become overwhelming when,
when you're,
when you're going after something like that,
you just handle what you handle that day.
And,
um,
I w I would do that.
I can tell you that if you're going to just start being a standup comedian,
la is a really hard place to start.
Yeah.
You kind of want to have your act together and have a little bit of momentum
when you go out there.
MMM.
But if you,
if you want to act and be an actor,
I mean there's,
that's what is a ton of work.
But,
um,
you know,
I don't know when you're going to go out to la,
but I'm sure wherever you live at,
there's,
there's some sort of place where you can start taking acting classes,
which is probably what I would do,
you know?
Um,
look,
if you just need a change of scenery and you want to go out in the fun in the
sun and go live down on the beach,
um,
Los Angeles and greater Los Angeles,
like south of there and everything is one of the great places you could ever
live in your life.
I know there's a ton of traffic,
but still some of the most beautiful women you ever going to see you don't want
if you get outside of La,
most of them aren't even in the business.
So now they just a beautiful woman on a beach,
you know?
And if that doesn't pick up your spirits,
I don't know what will,
but um,
you know,
if you seriously want to become an actor and that type of thing,
I wherever you're at,
I would start taking some acting classes to see if you actually do have a knack
for it.
Slash if you have a passion for it.
Do you go down there,
you start acting and then that makes you want to read some plays or makes you
want to go rewatch some movies to learn.
If you,
if you get like the bug,
you know and you really feel like this is something you want to pursue.
Um,
then I would work my ass off on that.
When you,
when I felt like I had my act together and I maybe done a player to uh,
go out to la,
get yourself a fucking agent.
[inaudible] and welcome to this fucked up business.
Like I've always said,
if a jackass like making get anywhere.
So could you.
Um,
all right,
next one.
A follow up to last week's miserable law student and some ass kissing.
All right,
well I'm going to go blow past the fucking ass kick ass kissing.
We'll read a,
a followup up bill.
First off,
I'm sorry about the length of this email.
I know you are busy.
Look,
you don't have to sugarcoat it.
You just write bills.
Sorry about the length of this email.
I know you suck at reading out loud.
Anyways,
I am a lawyer and this is just how I write and think I implore you to take 10
minutes to read it.
You know what,
when anybody uses the word implore and just cause you said you're a lawyer,
I just fixed it.
You,
you,
you're speaking to the jury and you just clapped both of your hands together,
like clash them together.
I implore you to look at the evidence.
Uh,
whatever that I am generally thinking you were thanking,
thanking you for being a good man.
If you want to use some of it,
of all of it,
feel free.
If not,
then no hard feelings.
I promise not to show up.
Do you house house some money mom for all right.
Okay.
Last week you read a letter from a kid who finished his first year of law school
who was trying to decide whether to drop out and he noted that he hated law law
school and was unhappy.
You told them to walk away speaking as an attorney with 10 years,
a hundred trials,
murderers,
rapers you name it.
Please let me say this.
Your advice was spot on.
Oh my God.
I thought you were gonna go the other way.
I,
you're going to be like,
let's say law school was terrible,
but once you get out of it and get it to the exciting world of sitting next to a
rapist till you know,
dead it,
but for some reason you have to defend them.
Um,
it makes it all worth worthwhile.
in my line of work,
we use the term jaded.
Jaded is the state,
uh,
where an attorney no longer gives a shit about his clients.
He simply does his job out of obligation and the need to bring in a paycheck.
Dude,
how the fuck can you be in that mindset
with somebody whose freedom is on the line?
Okay.
Do I swear to God?
Life is so fucking scary.
Once again,
one of the dumber things I've said,
no,
nothing will ever be dumber than when I was on Joe Rogan's podcast and I,
whatever the fuck I said about science,
like science is like fascinating.
It's neat.
I said something really stupid like the sciences,
like amazing.
Um,
listen,
listen to the Joe Rogan experience by the way.
Uh,
or reach out to one of his listeners and I'm sure they can tell you where it is
in that podcast where I said it is,
it's really,
it was so dumb.
I wasn't even embarrassed.
I almost felt like a,
I felt a freedom,
you know,
almost like I was like someone who,
if they come out of the closet,
you know,
I was coming out of the closet of stupidity.
I was tired of pretending to be this person that I wasn't.
Is he in the closet stupid or is he out of the clis out of the closet.
He announced to the world.
He like that Ellen member that,
Yep,
I'm gay.
I was that.
I should have been on the cover of Time magazine.
Yep.
I'm stupid.
Right?
Shrugging fucking little mixer in front of me is I record the podcast.
All right,
Dell,
we get it.
Okay.
I have 15 cases tomorrow.
This lawyer says each of was,
is a human being facing prison some for decades.
The truth is that I don't give a shit about a single one.
Oh my God,
I'll do my job,
but be it via the path of least resistance.
I just want to get back to my office and check La times.com I should probably
offer some excuse,
but I won't.
Truth is that every criminal defense attorney gets this way within three years
of passing the bar.
Wow.
Are you just speaking for yourself and thinking it's everybody?
Are you serious?
Oh my God,
God,
help me if I ever have to fucking go to,
okay.
Get a defense attorney.
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
between my first and second years of law school,
I learned that I love commercial aviation.
Oh,
so here it is.
So no,
dude,
you can't tell.
It's,
you can't say all lawyers are like this.
You want to be a pilot,
right?
Wait a second,
he says,
not flying,
but rather the aircraft itself.
I love every little nook and cranny,
every little screw in spring,
but I ignored my passion and press forward instead of following a dream and
moving to Seattle where Boeing is based,
I took a big paycheck as a public defender every day.
Now I look in the mirror and wonder what could have been.
All right.
Wait a minute.
Okay,
so you,
well,
the,
you can't lump all attorneys because some people,
it's their dream to be an attorney and they want to go there and they want to do
something.
Well,
I know,
I know a couple of great attorneys.
I have a great attorney.
The guy's a fucking animal.
He's up there prowl in this stage,
killing the crowd,
but doing it in a legal,
in the legal field.
Ah,
dude,
this kills this.
This fucking kills me
in all and all serious.
This kills me like nothing else.
Hearing stories of people wanting to do other things and they're not doing it.
Dude,
what's to stop you from quitting right now and just doing it.
It's not like you're 80 anyways,
between my first and second years of law school,
I learned that I love commercial.
I already read that part.
Sorry.
I'm,
the sad truth is that the law student who emailed you will not listen to your
advice.
He'll fend it.
Now that's not true,
sir.
Let's not super impose your life,
but okay,
he'll finish law school since he's already committed.
If you ever get the chance,
tell him that after he ignores you.
He does not need to practice law.
A law degree opens a ton of doors,
but the minute you take the bar,
you commit yourself to a life of pain and unhappiness.
I'm not kidding of the hundred plus lawyers.
I know not a single one likes their work.
Every one of them will tell you not to go to law school,
walk away from the bar,
go become a broker.
Go teach at a JC junior college.
Go work for a business,
open a spear fishing business in Bali,
whatever.
Just don't go and take the bar.
Okay?
There are two reasons I'm writing you today.
The second that I want to commend you and say that you are not a cont,
uh,
you speak your mind and using language you choose.
You followed your clothes path and I've made the sacrifices necessary to later
reap the rewards.
But more than that,
you have integrity and honor.
And for that,
I thank you Jesus.
Dude,
don't put me on that pedestal.
I'm a fucking moron.
Um,
and I have regrets to,
I'll wake up in the middle of the night and start screaming like Ron Burgundy.
Ha.
Oh.
Trying to fucking get those thoughts of regret out of my head.
We all have regrets,
sir.
And it's not too late for you to move to fucking Seattle.
You know what stopping you from moving to Seattle,
one conversation with the fucking people you work with and a couple of suitcases
that need to be filled.
That's it.
Who gives a fuck?
I'll tell you,
dude,
if you should,
you should follow your heart,
man.
And it's not too late.
And don't give a fuck if you got a kids and you're married,
move them.
All right?
Just move them up to save up some money.
Fucking move up there.
Live a little more modest.
It's a beautiful part of the country.
And uh,
you know,
your kids will watch WWE,
they'll see somebody pursuing a dream.
You'll be in a better mood.
You'll be a better husband and father if you're married.
All right?
And if you single,
you got no fucking excuse.
All right,
pack up all your three piece Matlock suits and go to Seattle.
Anyways,
a few months back,
a listener wrote about how his girlfriend was upset because he went to a strip
club and put oil on a woman's tits.
Your response was telling your advice was to reverse the situation.
His mind then apologize.
It was brilliant.
It was the advice that one man gives to another.
I could come up with countless examples,
but they'd all be saying the same thing.
You tell you listeners to be fair and honest with their women,
do I?
I always think I come off as a misogynistic Douche bag there.
You tell the sad and depressed to try to get out and then seek help if on Abel
you tell your young to save their money and you tell people not to use drugs,
but for legitimate reasons.
Um,
I could go on and on,
but I'd be repeating the point.
Sad point is that your podcast demonstrates what it is to be a good man.
Jesus Christ.
I was,
Nia was listening to this shit.
She'd be laughing our ass off.
I appreciate this.
You said you Sarah,
good man.
Never let that voice in your head tell you otherwise.
Well,
listen,
yeah.
Uh,
I dunno.
It's killing me that you,
that people like yourself,
your act,
you'd like,
you're acting like wherever you live.
Okay?
Between you and Seattle,
like you're in your,
you're behind,
you know,
the old fucking eastern block and there's a bunch of guard towers,
and there's some sort of war zone between you and Seattle.
There isn't,
you know,
sir,
you could actually practice law in Seattle.
You know,
if you just wanted to make money on the side,
you know
this,
get this.
Listen,
okay.
Sit down tonight and figure out a fucking way to get your ass to Seattle.
And I guarantee you,
when you sit down and you start writing it out your game plan,
you're going to feel the excitement that you,
that you're missing.
Being a lawyer and being a lawyer is not a bad job.
It's just not what you were supposed to do.
Okay?
Because I guarantee you the same way you look at an airplane and you love every
screw,
every spring,
every nook and cranny of an aircraft.
There's lawyers who they loved the smell of a courtroom.
They love that big wooden fucking desk.
They loved the closing argument.
They loved that moment,
the turn,
you know,
whatever.
What you just fucking flipping around on the other guy.
You know,
they love defending.
They prosecuting.
They love the fucking sound of their shoes walking across the courtroom.
They love it.
They fucking love it.
You do not love it.
So my advice to you is
get your fucking ass to Seattle.
All right?
Jesus Christ.
Who gives it?
What?
What are you worried about,
sir?
You're not going to have,
you're not going to have a what do you not going to have flat screen TV doesn't
cause shit.
Now y'all have enough,
dude,
as long as you're willing to make the fucking sacrifice,
you can make it happen.
All right,
well what's the matter?
What do,
what are you gonna you know?
Oh,
I have to eat fucking great nuts every day.
Who gives a fuck?
You know,
peanut butter and jelly sandwiches for lunch.
Who gives a fuck?
You know,
watched this thing on 60 minutes about fucking boy soldiers,
people,
kids getting kidnapped turned into murderers,
you know,
don't even have a fucking childhood.
They get sucked right into fighting a goddamn war following this God damned
basically the closest thing to a Zombie I've ever seen in my life and their
whole lives get fucking ruined.
You know,
you're a lawyer in a free country who wants to move to Seattle?
Don't fucking disappoint me.
You better write me back and tell me you're in Seattle.
All right.
But please,
for the love of God,
don't ever become a jaded pilot.
Oh my God,
I'm so fucking bored with flying.
I just have this feeling that I just want to push the fucking,
what is it?
The yoke,
whatever the fuck they got.
Damn stick.
Sometimes I feel like I just want to push it forward.
Um,
crazy x billion catching up on the podcast and you just told a story about a
woman you used to date that threatened to kill you and then made a tin of
brownies.
Yeah.
She said she was going to stab me.
She didn't say fatally.
Umm,
that's where you ended the story,
Dude.
How did you finally get rid of her in case you're wondering?
Yes,
my life is that Dell that I actually give a shit how the story ends.
Uh,
no,
I did kind of leave you hanging.
How did I get rid of her?
Um,
okay.
I was really young and naive and this is what she would do.
She would call me up and I would pick up the phone.
This was before caller ID and shit.
So I picked the phone up and it would be her and then it would be,
listen,
I don't want to talk to you.
And then she'd start crying and I was an idiot because I thought she was crying
legitimately.
I didn't realize that it was a manipulation tactic to make me feel bad and make
me feel like I'm a fucking bully.
So I'd stay on the phone,
talk her down and be nice to her where she wasn't crying anymore.
And then we would end with a nice ending to the phone conversation.
But in her psycho stalker world,
that meant that we were somehow still connected and back together.
And then she would call me again and I would say,
listen,
I don't want to talk to you.
Then she'd start crying.
It was this fucking circle.
I that I couldn't get out of cycle,
I should say.
MMM.
There's funny,
ever since Dan Cooks vicious circle came out.
I never say vicious cycle anymore.
It was a,
it was a cycle I could not get out of.
Um,
so finally my manager at the time just says,
listen,
cause I said,
what the fuck do I do?
He goes,
listen,
when she calls you pick up the phone.
If it's her,
just hang up.
Just hang up.
And that's what I just started doing.
I would pick up the phone and she'd be like,
Billy and I would just click,
I just fucking,
I just hang up.
And uh,
within 10 days she stopped fucking calling me,
make granted at that point I was living on the other side of the country for
half of the fucking time,
but I just kept,
I just kept hanging up.
And,
um,
I did have the advantage,
like I said,
if not still being in the same city,
but what you have to do is if you have a girl like that as you just aura guy,
well guy is different.
I really feel bad for women when it comes to shit like that because guys,
um,
you know,
I guess there are women out there that actually take it to some ridiculous
violent level,
but obviously guys do it more often.
But I'm,
so this is my advice for guys.
If you have some crazy lady and your fucking life,
that's what you do.
You just gotta.
You can't give him anything because people like that.
You give them one little fucking ray of light,
they latch onto that and they think you guys are getting fucking married or some
shit.
Um,
all right.
The crazy ex,
that's how it ended.
I just stopped fucking,
it's not really exciting.
I just kept fucking hanging up on her and eventually she went away in every once
in a while,
uh,
she would try to fucking reach back out and I just,
just,
no,
just nothing.
Beat it.
Leave me alone.
I think she reached out and tried to friend me on my space a long time ago when
I just did not accept it.
And then that was the last day of,
or heard of her.
That's how you do it.
Um,
all right.
Cancer Lady.
Question.
Morning Bill.
Big Fan.
Go Fuck Yourself.
I've got myself into an inevitable situation and now needs some advice on how to
get myself out of it.
A few months back,
I started seeing this girl who,
a few weeks in found out she could potentially have cancer.
Oh,
Gigi tion Jesus.
Dude.
Wow.
I wasn't an intern.
I wasn't that into this girl to begin with,
but figured I'd have some fun and when the time came to end it I would.
But after she told me about the possible cancer diagnosis,
I felt bad for wanting to end it.
So like an idiot,
I stuck around.
Uh,
Jesus.
Well,
I,
if you're young,
I can't fault you for that.
You know,
you now,
you think you're fucking doing or if you're doing her a favor,
you're actually making it worse.
Ah.
Oh my God.
Dude,
I'm getting like Deuce chills.
How do you get out of this?
Oh cause no matter what it's going to make it seem like you left because she had
cancer anyways.
A few months have passed and the cancer scare is over,
but now I'm stuck in this situation.
No you're not.
That's your green light.
Fucking screen doors open,
run out of there.
Needless to say,
she's a lot more into this relationship than I am and I just want out and away
from her maniac kids asap.
Dude,
I bet you fucking dimes to dollar.
There was no cancer fucking scare.
I bet she did that to suck you into the fucking relationship.
I saw a thing on TV the other day and you know,
God knows if you see it on TV,
it's gotta be true.
Some woman did that,
told everybody that she was dying of cancer,
including her fucking boyfriend.
The fuck head went ahead and married her
idiot.
Anyways,
he said,
is there a smooth way out of this cluster fuck without making it obvious that I
only stuck around cause of the cancer?
Is there a good exit strategy?
Thanks for the help and come to Toronto soon,
asshole.
Um,
there's no smooth way out of a fucking relationship.
There isn't.
You just have to sit down and say,
listen,
we need to talk.
Okay.
And then they go,
okay.
And you say,
listen,
I'm not,
I'm not happy.
I think you're a great person and everything,
but I'm just not feeling like you're the one boom right there.
What did that take eight seconds to say that he'd just say it.
You just say it.
Just say it and just get it out there and then the flood,
the fucking chips fall.
She's gonna to cry.
She might scream,
she might throw shit out yet,
you know,
neighbors will be peeking through their cartons,
but just say that.
Okay.
She might try to get you to fucking go back into,
you know,
manipulate.
What do,
maybe we can work it out.
Would you want to talk to them?
Maybe we could talk to somebody about it.
I know I just,
this is truly what I'm feeling and it isn't fair to you for me to continue
sticking around.
It's just preventing you from meeting the person you're supposed to be with.
And myself also,
I'm sorry,
I feel horrible,
but I have to be honest with you and you can't fuck with that.
And then you're out.
I mean,
no,
you're not out.
You got to sit through another hundred 80 minutes of fucking histrionics and
everything,
but,
but you're out.
Okay.
And you just sit down and tell yourself,
sir,
that you know what?
Today at two o'clock in the afternoon,
I'm talking to my girlfriend soon to be my ex girlfriend.
And you know what?
From two o'clock to five o'clock is going to suck fucking donkey fucking balls.
All right,
but five oh one on is going to be great.
Yeah.
All right.
This is like,
you're a fucking junkie.
I saw that on a,
uh,
doctor,
um,
and I was fucking doctor shows
the fuck is it?
I can't remember shit anymore.
He was basically talking about how addicts will go through fucking eight nine 10
years of hell because they don't want to go through 10 days of a of detox.
Rather than dealing with 10 days of retching and vomiting and feeling like
you're fuck,
you're like your fingernails hurt.
10 days of that,
you're going to go through 10 days of hell and be living out on the fucking
street just to avoid those 10 days of fucking withdrawals.
That's what you're doing.
If you stay in a fucking relationship,
you don't want to be all right.
Just get the fuck out.
Get out now and make me proud.
All right,
dilemma.
Dear bill,
your Monday morning podcasts has become religion over the past five weeks.
I came to see it,
the PABST theater in Milwaukee a year ago or so and have been a fan ever since.
I just thought I might bring to your attention to question that my roommates and
I disagree upon completely.
I'm in a fight to the death against an opponent of equal size,
strength and skill.
Which weapon would you rather have on your side?
A 20 ounce hammer with a nail nail removing hook on the end or a 28 ounce
wouldn't Louisville slugger?
The question is,
that's not even as a joke.
Question is,
which is the better weapon and your opponent is essentially you the fucking
Louisville slugger.
Without a fucking doubt.
I can get you from a distance.
What the fuck are you gonna do with Your Hammer?
You got a hammer,
you've got to get insight.
Let's,
you're going to throw it at me and I got a bat.
I'll fucking hit it right back at Ya.
I'll hit it over your head.
Now you have no fucking weapon and now I'm coming right doing that fucking over,
under,
over,
right in front of my face.
I could do it.
I could literally have that thing.
Okay.
I bet.
Fucking right handed.
They're the secrets over.
You now know my stats throws right batch.
Fucking right.
Um,
drums,
right,
plays guitar,
lefty rights,
lefty.
I'm all over the fucking map,
so I fucking,
I'd have it in my left hand.
My,
my front hand.
Like,
if I was up at bat and I would come in,
do a couple step in,
step out,
step in,
and then I just fucking wacky and your shit.
And as you did that stupid little hop.
I'm coming up top now.
Um,
first I'm doing short,
quick ones real quick.
Fucking you up so you count.
You know,
so you don't catch the bat.
And then as you really start getting fucked up,
then I'm there.
Now I'm going for a double,
then I'm going up the fucking goddamn warning track and then that's it.
And I'm swinging for a home run and you're fucking done.
Split your head like a fucking melon.
Fuck you in and you and your hammer.
It's over.
Um,
whoever's picking the hammer is his thinking.
Like what would I rather get hit with once with a bat at once with a hammer?
Hammers made on a metal bats made out of wood.
What's the stronger fucking material?
Obviously of God Damn Hammer.
Right?
Metal.
All right.
But what they're not thinking about is the distance.
You don't want one.
She went,
she emailed.
Why don't you call on the Joe Rogan podcast,
Joe Rogan experience.
You'd be able to break that down.
All people.
You know what,
that's a podcast for this week.
Uh,
here's what's going on at the,
uh,
the all things comedy network.
Uh,
we got deep shit with baron Vaughn on March.
Oh,
okay.
Deep Shit with Baron von.
He recorded a half hour in Boston is coming up.
It's going to be on TV at some point.
Really?
But that,
that's the promo that I get up.
She's fucking,
what are we doing over here?
Baron von recorded a half hour special on March 11th for comedy central.
Lookout for it.
So to Joe to Roseau over there.
Um,
yeah.
Why didn't I look this over the flop house?
Episode Number One,
22,
the flophouse live show on June 8th,
and uh,
tried Becca 200 Hudson street tickets not on sale yet.
Um,
I'm an idiot.
I can't even fucking read this shit.
What's wrong with me?
You know what?
Lemme just gonna read the final law advertisement for this week and then I'm
going to tell you a funny story.
Actually,
I'm not,
I just said that.
I'm going to tell you a funny story because I wanted you to fucking hang in
there.
That's what I did.
You see what he did there?
I just fucking lie to you after that lawyer said that I was a great man.
I just lied to you.
Um,
I,
oh,
I know what the teaser,
remember I was talking about Ting at the beginning of this podcast.
Now you think in,
what is Ting?
Ting is a mobile service mobile.
That makes sense.
Ting is no a no BS mobile service.
Uh,
it's an M v n o reseller of the national nationwide Spiritan network.
they got a new hotspot.
They've just added a three g slash four g.
Why Max Hotspot to the Ting lineup.
The Sierra wireless overdrive pro can be had and refurbished for just 30 bucks,
uh,
in February.